- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by university of California
television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
- We are the paradoxical ape, bipedal,
naked, large brained,
long the master of fire, tools, and
language.
But still trying to understand ourselves,
aware that death is
inevitable, yet filled with optimism. We
grow up slowly, we hand down knowledge, we
empathize and deceive. We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts from diverse
disciplines to exchange insights on who we
are and how we got here. An exploration
made possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
- [Rick Potts] I just have some brief
concluding wrap up comments that I would
like to make, making some observations.
We've come a long way in this symposium
across an extraordinary range of time
scales. Probably a greater range of time
than has been attempted by any CARTA
symposium I would suspect. And I would
like to, given that we've made
this transition from
the study of human evolution and
paleoclimate, to the present and
predictions about the future, I'd like to
take us back to CARTA's mandate to
understanding where we come from. And to
try to provide that my wrap up comments as
a way of framing what we've heard in the
last several talks. I would have five
observations that arise from the study of
human origins that are worthy to consider
the context of the human present
and future. I mean, there are many, many
more observations that could be made but,
the use focusing on
the specific topic of this symposium.
The first is, we examined early on is that
the predecessors they were the adaptations
of our predecessors. Not just their
physical appearances but also their
behaviors, their ways of life, evolved in
a earth that was trending in particular
directions toward drying and cooling but
also in a highly dynamic world. A world of
dynamic climates, of dynamic landscapes,
changing resources, changes in social
surroundings and so on. And so many
aspects of the CARTA mission explore
these areas. Now, that's the first. The
second is that the baseline adaptations of
our species evolved, embedded in
ecosystems. Embedded in the dynamic
environments and climates those ancestors
of ours encountered. The fundamental
charge of paleoanthropology, the study of
human evolution is to understand how human
qualities, including our capacity for the
diversity of cultural histories that have
unfolded over the past thousands of years
and are, of course, unfolding now.
That these qualities have emerged in the
natural world, in or by the processes of
nature. So in other words, the takeaway
message there is that humans are integral
to life, humans are integral to the
history of life and that is inescapable
and it's inescapable in the anthroposy.
Third, the overarching narrative of human
evolution has significantly changed. It is
a change from a worldview and a story of
how the human lineage came to supposedly
have control and dominion over some
primordial ancestral environment, mastery
of that environment. And it has come about
through scientific studies, particularly
looking at human origins in its
environmental context to a story of
evolving resilience, adaptability and
persistent change and the challenges of
survival. With regard to my own research,
I used to see like so many others, Africa,
the place where I do my
a lot of my field research as the cradle
of human kind. A kind of nurturing image.
The caldron of human evolution is the term
I now prefer, reflecting the churning
process that define the line between
survival and extinction in the era of
human origins. The fourth point follows
from the third one. And that is that the
ways of life of our evolutionary ancestors
and cousins have come and gone. Extinction
has involved not only the end of gene
pools and lineages, it has also entailed
the demise of ways of life. So for
example, a Homo erectus was certainly an
ancestor of Homo sapiens, the way or ways
of life of Erectus are not longer around.
Out of the minimum of
depending upon whether again this term
lumper or splitter by how you divide up
the fossil record. But out of the minimum
that most paleoanthropologists recognize
of 18 different homo lineages that had
significant time depth to them. Only one
lineage, of course our species survives.
All the other ways of life of earlier
hominance have gone extinct, even though
each species possessed at least some of
the unique distinguishing
qualities of our species.
Now, I have come across people who have
said, "Yeah. But we are around." And
that's cool. If anyone sees that as good,
it must involve a very jaded view of
biodiversity including biodiversity in our
own evolutionary tree. The ways of life of
our ancestors and evolutionary cousins
were sustainable but only for a time, and
they ultimately came to an end. And fifth
and finally, Homo sapiens lives in the
world by altering it. It is our survival
mechanism. Even simple interactions with
the environment as we look back through
pre-historic time and making up a stone
tool, moving resources around the
environment, managing fire, building
shelters, planting a seed to try to secure
food, all of these basic activities change
the immediate surroundings. And this way
of life essential to all human beings
today no matter where they
live on earth,
was so successful that it
spread worldwide.
And so now we find ourselves where the
planetary scales of human influence is
unquestionable. We have the rapidity of
change in landscape that may be quite
different from anything that has ever been
experienced before. In evolutionary
history the planet is packed with people,
and are ways of changing our immediate
surroundings and also surroundings that
affect people in terms of the atmosphere
and the ocean. And places affect people
that we have never met and will never
meet. And so this afternoon we have heard
evidence and arguments that are grounds
for pessimism and optimism about the
future. And whether the glass is half full
or half empty, I think that we have before
us say, grand societal project. And that
grand societal project is to be carried
out by the first species that has
awareness of extinction, including it's
own extinction but as also the extinction
of other forms of life on earth.
We are aware of human societies on all
parts of the globe and we are connected to
them. It seems to me that many of the
problems that we have addressed here,
having yet brought up the matter of
whether the scale or the problem can be
matched by the scale of our compassion. We
are a species capable of developing
principles, of living in a purposeful and
meaningful world, and acting according to
those principles and values, depending
upon how much we care. The future will be
a world of our own making, that's who we
are. I'd like to thank my wonderful
colleagues who have made presentations
today and we are very eager to open up the
conversation with you all, thank you for
being a terrific audience.
- [Charles Kennel] This is the moment in
which I act as your master of ceremonies.
We had a tremendous number of responses
to the questions. And I had to exercise
the chairman's privilege and select a few
that I thought were of general interest,
and I also tried to make sure that
everybody got
asked a question. And so, I'm first of all
going to ask the person to whom the
question is directed, to come up here and
give the answer from here. So we've got,
surprisingly, an interesting list of
questions. The first one is the simplest
to ask and maybe one of the more difficult
to answer. And it's for Professor Hublin,
and it's simply, "Did homo sapiens kill
Neanderthals?"
- [Prof Hublin] Yeah. That's a simple one
The answer is probably, occasionally. This
being said, there are many ways to take
the land and the resource of other people
than killing individuals. This is a little
bit politically incorrect but we like to
think on hunter or gatherers as equal
pacifist or people living in equilibrium
with other groups and et cetera. But we
know that chimpanzees go to war some time
and modern humans did quite well. So it
would be very surprising than between the
common ancestral of chimpanzees and humans
and modern humans nothing similar happens.
But this being said, we don't have any
direct evidence of that.
- [Charles] Thank you. So here is one for
Dr. deMenocal. Can you come up? There
you are. Here's one. "Are ocean currents
changing fast enough to impact human
existence?" In other words, the shifting
monsoons resulted in wiping out ancient
civilizations. Are oceans circulations,
you think, it's going to do the same
change is going to do the same to us?
- [Dr. deMenocal] That's a great question
whoever asked that, and thank you for
that. Actually a colleague of mine Richard
Seager at Lamont-Doherty Earth Observatory
where I work has actually addressed that
very question. The answer is yes, that
changes in oceans currents
actually that changes in sea surface
temperature distributions, where it's
warming and where it's cooling is shifting
where it rains actually. And so, that's
one of the reasons why the American
Southwest and somewhat for California is
experiencing exceptional drought right
now. It's due to changes in the ocean
currents. So this isn't so much the
overturning circulation as is the wind of
uncirculation. But nonetheless, that is
contributing to impacting our
sustainability. So, great question.
- [Charles] Thank you. Looks like
we are going to
I'll select a few more. For Rick, I've got
a question for you. It's a chicken and egg
question. "Was the development of
agriculture at least in part a consequence
of increased population no longer being
supportable by the
hunter/gatherer economy?"
- [Rick Potts] That is a question that was
in my understanding was first addressed
by an  anthropologist, Ester Boserup, a
demographer and anthropologist who
suggested exactly that. That it was a
population pressure thing. I think one of
the things that's interesting when I think
also of Jack's talk and of Bill Ruddiman's
talk is to recognize that the origin of
agriculture didn't happen just once. There
were multiple centers of agriculture. And
that there were
it's hard to say that, well because 12000
years ago for example, that there was one
thing going on. I think that there
may be examples of how populations due to
the archeological evidence, that
populations were moving up and down,
different elevations, and had quite an
adaptable system. That there is only
really one answer to whether population
pressure results in settling down and
domestication and the
intensification of agriculture.
When you look, for example, in Mexico, the
independent center of agricultural origins
in Mexico, you actually see thousands of
years. This is the work of Kent Flannery,
but thousands of years where it wasn't
just hunting and gathering or agriculture,
it was actually mixed and people were
doing whatever they could to get enough
food. And to, in some ways to buffer some
of the seasonality, differences, times of
dearth and drought. And so I think that we
have to come up with a more meaningful and
more, in fact, more complicated scenario
that it's just population pressure that
pushes agriculture and that it's a simple
and easy transition.
- [Charles] I'm going to take one. I don't
know to whom it is addressed, but the
question is, "Do any of the changes in
climate correlate with the geomagnetic
polar shift?" And what I do know from my
earlier work in geomagnetism is the idea
that there are occasions in the evolution
by the way, the geomagnetic pole moves
around with about a 20 thousand-year
cycle, and it reverses direction. And
during the period of time when it's
reversing direction, the magnetic field
that the earth is very small relative to
other times. And that lets more cosmic
rays into the lower atmosphere, and
there's a thought that that can affect
populations of animals through a radiation
of their genetic material. So with that,
I'm going to finish that one. Here's one
for Bill Ruddiman. This one's going to
provoke a little bit of discussion here.
"The dating of the inception of the
anthropocin has political implications."
So I'm sure you'd struggle with, does
moving the date back to the rise of
agriculture 10,000 years ago dilute the
recognition of the effects of the rapid
carbon dioxide increase today?
- [Robert Ruddiman] I don't think it
changes any the mainstream view of
what's been happening for the last
100, 150 away. I look at it, I'm
mainstream climate scientist, I look at
the rise of carbon dioxide, methane and
temperature in the last 150 to 200 years
as a sharp acceleration, the same as every
other mainstream scientist. What I would
add to it is there's this long prior, slow
period where we are adding methane and
carbon dioxide. We are not so much as
warming the earth as we are cancelling or
cooling, part of a cooling. So this is
still the same way as it was before, we
are just adding an earlier story.
- [Charles] So, here's one for Jeff
Severinghaus. "How are oceans suffering
acidification, different rates and how
will our climates
marine terrestrial change?"
- [Jeff] Yeah. Thanks for asking that
excellent question. Of course, this as
Naomi said, that this is the other problem
besides the other CO2 problem. CO2
is causing ocean acidification and quite
separate from its climate impacts of
course. And that's a serious issue for
many organisms that secrete calcium
carbonate shells. It's going to get harder
and harder for them to secrete their
shells and of course, the impacts are not
uniformly distributed across the globe.
They are much worse in the colder parts of
the ocean and somewhat milder in the
warmer parts of the ocean. That just
simply is because the calcium and
carbonate physical solubility is much
higher in the colder parts of the ocean.
So, yes, it certainly is uneven, it's in
fact going to wipe out the deep dwelling
corals probably before it wipes out
anything else. So yeah, it certainly part
of the ongoing extinction story.
Does that answer it?
- [Charles] And I have another, don't go
away. As it turns out, I found another one
for you. "What was the cause of the
moisture for the high snow load in the
north during the last ice age? Was it the
Arctic Ocean, was that ocean and icery?
- [Jeff] Probably not. The Arctic
Ocean probably was covered by what we call
an ice shelf, a floating glacier during
the last ice age. So it wasn't a source of
moisture but it's not so much that there
was a lot of extra snowfall in the north
so much as it was a lot colder and so the
snow didn't melt, and so it stuck around.
That's in fact, the accumulation rates
that we see in the Greenland ice course
are about half and during the glacial of
what they are today. So colder equals
drier, it's a good rule of thumb.
- [Charles] Thank you. So, I have a
question and I think, if I'm right, I can
divide between two speakers. The first
part of the question is, "How accurate are
the temperature rise predictions for
2050?" And I think that's one for Ram. But
then, "What will the effects be on
vegetation and agriculture?" That could be
Dr. Hadly. So if you both would come up.
- [Ram] Yeah. I remember what Charlie
said, "Predictions are difficult
particularly of the future." So, in
general, over climate model and
uncertainties but the 90% confidence
interval is (+) or (-) 50%. Remember of
the two degrees, the planet has already
warmed by .85. So you apply the
uncertainty of (+) or (-) 50% to the
projection. So when I say two, it could
one and a half, or it could be two and a
half. I won't be alive if it's
disapproved, but that's
- [Charles] So
sorry, forgive me.
- [Dr. Hadley] It's okay. So the question
was I believe about forests or vegetation
and I'll answer the agriculture question
first and say that, the green revolution
did a lot to feed all these people that we
have on the planet. And really, the only
place that hasn't truly been transformed
by the green revolution is Africa. And the
reason it hasn't is because Africa is not
one country. It's many countries. And each
of we tend to think
about Africa as a
country, but those boundaries play a big
role in how resources, particularly water
and infrastructure move between those
boundaries. And so in some places, there's
been too much water for
agriculture to really
the green revolution to take hold, and
other parts of Africa there's not been
enough. So I'll say that, increasing
temperatures are only likely to exacerbate
that and from what I know about our stocks
of seeds and the wild relatives of our
cultivars, we don't have. Right?
We have eliminated so many of the wild
cultivars and the wild relatives of our
crops that we don't have the genomic
repertoire of the plants that we subsist
on to really handle two to four degrees
increase in temperature. And then in terms
of vegetation around the world, I'll
answer it in terms of not so much climate
change but deforestation. It's an enormous
problem and I have this extraordinary
picture of the Amazon that shows it's from
satellite photo and it shows that you can
define the boundary of South America. The
Amazon, the boundary between the land and
the sea based purely on individual clouds.
It expresses that every day trees are
respiring and releasing oxygen into the
atmosphere, and including they are
releasing water vapor. Every day, trade
winds come and they push those clouds up
toward the front of the Andes where they
then rise and come back
over the Amazon as rain.
In the absence of trees, the tropical
forest there there's poor soil and it's
really difficult to get tropical forest to
grow again. So our deforestation is
actually feeding back, it's causing a
state shift in climate
both locally and globally.
- [Charles] Now I'm going to take a
question for myself. And the reason is,
the question was so good because it
pointed out the things that I should have
said and didn't say. And so I feel
obligated to correct, record it. And there
are two of them here. The first one is,
"What you are calling a hiatus is actually
a decrease in the rate of warming."
That's absolutely true. The public calls
it a hiatus. The climate science committee
has adopted the name to describe that
period, but in fact, the rate of increase
over the last 17 years is probably about a
third what it had been in the previous 25
years or so. So that's correct. Then the
second part was, "In the past, there have
been changes where the rate of warming
increased." We just came out of one. It
was surface temperature warming and from
'75 to '98 the temperature increased by
about a half a degree centigrade.
And then it increased by much last in the
last 17 years even though we were putting
more energy from the greenhouse effect
into the system. That energy was going
deep into the oceans. So in the past have
there been changes where the rate of
warming increased? Yes. And in fact, you
could argue that the change that I
described is just simply a change that the
climate science, what is called the
Pacific Decadal Oscillation which
oscillates back and forth every 30 years
or so. With the additional caveat that
greenhouse warming thinned the Arctic ice
and created a much more rapid entrees a
decrease of ice than we would have thought
of. The other question is, "We are aware
of the effect of the gulf stream on
Europe. Is there a similar ocean effect on
the Pacific, and how does it affect
climate and weather in North America?" And
actually, I showed both of them.
The Pacific one is the El Nino/La Nina
cycle. There are studies of tree rings
that go back about 1000 years. And studies
of lake sediments in Ecuador that show
during El Nino period is a great
deposition of mud at the bottom of the
lake. The El Nino cycle has been with us
for at least 5000 years. And it leads to
dramatic changes in the climate in west
and north America as I indicate. So the El
Nino is to west and north America as the
Atlantic oscillation is to Europe,
Easter North America. And we have the
and then if you are interested, for the
rest of the world, we have the north, the
east Asia and Indian Monsoons are large
climate cycles that have big impact. So
thank you for your indulgence. Rick Potts,
here's one for you. "Could we frame the
legend of the great flood as a period of
climate change leading to a large loss of
population and a bottleneck leading
through cultural evolution?" That's an
easy one I think.
- [Rick Potts] In March, I spoke at a
conference convened by the AAAS, The
American Association for the Advancement
of Science. It was a conference attended
by 100 scientists and 100 Christian
evangelicals. And I thought we made
progress in conversation and discussion.
I'm not quite sure I can make progress in
answering this question.
But I think that the
like all narratives of origin that emerge
out of traditional society and traditional
text that they often take something that
is unique to a particular region, and may
see that region because that's all they
know as something that is worldwide. It's
their cosmos, that's the essence of how we
develop the powerful stories, we do about
how we relate to the world. Now we have as
part of our cross-cultural endeavor to
understand one another.
Something that crosses philosophies,
cultures, languages, religions and so on,
we have at least one other avenue with
regard to understanding the story of how
humans in a broader sense came into being.
And when we put that into a climate
perspective, yes, we see that there were
times that were far wetter than others.
The part of the question that deals with
the matter of bottleneck, that maybe we
are referring to the idea that geneticists
have come up with
some geneticists, that there was either a
very, very long period of time, a very low
effect of population size, that is
breeding populations size. The group that
comes out of Utah would say, perhaps
10,000 in breeding population size, about
10,000 individuals. There have been then
studies, one published in PNAS,
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences in the late 2000s, 2008 I
believe, that look at a whole variety of
genetic biomarkers.
And suggested that the effect of a
breeding population size of our species,
from which all modern human genetic
diversity, nuclear genomic diversity arose
was from a breeding population size of
perhaps 600. Yeah. We were perhaps once an
endangered species ourselves. That should
give us pause. And so, the one thing that
seems to be by many people who work in
Africa, they do not see the explosion of
Mt. Toba in Indonesia as being the driver
of that, but rather that was a time of
very strong oscillation between wet and
dry cycles. And a number of us who have
gotten drill cores out of the ground to
look at long climate sequences over the
last 500,000 years are going to take a
very close look at that. But that's as
much of an answer as I have right at the
moment, I'll try to come back in a couple
of years and tell you the answer.
- [Charles] Thank you. Now, I'm going to
close, we have several more questions but
I'm going to warn all the speakers at the
end that I'm going to ask them to come
here and give a brief answer to the last
question. And so, here's one, and I think,
I didn't quite know who to address it, but
I think I'll address it to Ram. "Recent
results in behavioral economics say humans
aren't rational. How do we design
strategies for survival as a civilization
that transcend
national and cultureal limitations?"
- [Ram] Charlie, I clearly told you my
origin is in quantum mechanics. Yeah. I
don't know if I'm really qualified to
answer this. Certainly, as of the behavior
issue I don't know if I can touch that.
But clearly what I would emphasize is what
we concluded and you were there at the
Vatican workshop, thinking about the
sustainability issue. It brings in
intergenerational equity, generations to
come damaging the planett. And
intragenerational equity, which is what
few of us are doing is going to
negatively impact. Then it's clear we
fundamentally need to change our attitude
towards nature and to each other. And how
do you make that happen? Maybe a social
scientist could tap into the rational part
of our brain. But I certainly think this
is really the domain of the religions.
They talk about morality and the smaller
issue, we all have the change of a
behavior. So I would more appeal to the
religious leaders to help us out than
appeal to the rational part of our brain.
- [Charles] And I would just add that one
theme that lodged in my mind from that
great conference goes something like this,
"The society that cares for all its
members will also care for all the
environment and if we don't do that, they
both will go down together." So I now
have two questions for Naomi. Well,
there's two of them and then we'll end
with our final question here. For you
Naomi, "In light of Hanson's action and
critical feedback and the need for
disruptive politics as you argued, what is
your advice to young scientists?"
- [Naomi] All right. Well, it's a very
good question. I think my advice to young
scientists is this, we all have to do the
interventions that we are able to do based
on our personalities, and our talents and
our skillset. And if you are an aspiring
scientist and you are good at science,
then that's what you should be doing. So I
don't think scientists need to become
politicians or artists or something like
that, I don't think that makes sense. But
I do think that scientists have very
important role to play in terms of
explaining not just the facts of the
science but what they mean for people's
lives. And I do think the scientific
community needs to do that because no one
else really can. Well, historians of
science can but there's just aren't very
many of us. So, I think it's that
explaining, what is the temperature rise
of one-degree mean?
Most people have no idea.
Governor Kulongoski of Oregon who came
here a couple of years ago when his son
Justin was a student at Scripps, he said,
"I go out into the countryside, I talk to
farmers and I say, 'it's going to be two
degrees warmer,' well, first of all they
think it's Fahrenheit. And then they
think, 'Oh, so instead of a 68 degree day
it's a 70 degree day' that sounds good."
Right? So that translation of the science
into it's human meaning, is really, really
crucial. I think that all scientists
can contribute to that.
- [Charles] And this next question is a
precursor to the final one.
And while Naomi is speaking, I
would like to ask all the speakers to come
to the front. And you may or may not wish
to answer the question that I pose or has
been posed but I would like you up here,
please. So Naomi for you, "Given the
conclusion that we could all have a mass
extinction in the 21st Century, how do you
determine that humans will not
also become extinct?"
- [Naomi] Well, it's certainly possible
and never say never. But if you look at
the history of the
the geological history that Liz Hadley
showed us and that many of us are familiar
with, there have been five mass
extinctions in the history of the planet,
four and a half billion years. So that
means, statistically, the odds of a mass
extinction any time in our lifetime is
extremely low. Although some people have
argued we may be facing a sixth extinction
based on what we are doing to other
species on this planet, but that's a sixth
extinction which we survive but wipe out
all these other things. So it's not that
it isn't possible that it could happen,
it's just not very likely. And I don't
think it's really the relevant question,
because if we are thinking about ourselves
and our lives and the interventions that
we can make as people living today, really
the big question facing us is
the next 100 years.
It's what happens between now and 2050,
whether we stay below that two degree
limit or head towards four degrees and
beyond. And the consequences, the
different between staying below two
degrees versus going to four, five or six
or beyond are very, very grave. And so I
really think that's the
question that we need to focus on.
- [Charles] Thank you. Okay, gang. Now,
here's the question and I'm going to ask
you to think of a brief answer, but it
will be a yes or no question with a couple
of sentences as to why you think so. All
right, so, here's the question. "After
this insightful and informative symposium
on climate change, should we walk away
more hopeful or less hopeful?" Somebody
would want to give it a try?
- [female] I think that the
answer is yes.
- [Charles] I'd like everyone
to give it a try.
- [male] I think we should be more
optimistic.
- [male] [Inaudible 00:38:46].
- [Charles] Let's use the
microphone, yeah.
- [Prof Hublin] I think we should be more
optimistic because there's a global
awareness of the problem of course.
- [Dr. Hadley] I think that because you
are here, that's hopeful for me. Generally
I'm pretty depressed about this day in
the world. But I'll say that one thing I
didn't tell you about, although Ram really
gave a nice example of is that I think
that we need to look for an inspiration to
the three billion people that are living
below poverty. And it's not so much that
they should look to us but we should look
to them, because they are leap frogging
technology and they are showing us how
well we can do with little. That's what
gives me optimism in the world.
- [Ram] I strongly endorse what Dr.
Hadley said, absolutely. I'm certainly
very hopeful. Remember, don't forget it's
$450 problem. It's just climate change.
- [Prof deMenocal] Looks like we are all
optimists here. My view is really simple
is that, I think we have to be optimistic.
And the reason is that, any other view is
just too depressing. It's impossible to
tell the lowest three quarters of the
world's population that things are going
to be worse for them than they are
already, because we are already pretty
dire. And so we have to not only envision
a future that's better but we actually
have to make it. So, that's my view.
- [Severinghaus] Well I'm an optimist too.
I believe that this is just actually very
hopeful situation in many ways and partly
because if you look back at history again,
I love history. The whole recognition of
disease as a problem having to do with
public health and sanitation, that didn't
happen overnight. There were public health
advocates that were working for maybe half
a century, maybe even a whole century
before we got sewage treatment systems. I
like to tell the audiences I speak to that
there's no such thing as republican sewage
treatment and democratic sewage treatment.
Everybody is in favor of it, right? So
that's a way to look at this problem, it
didn't get solved overnight, but we are
going to get there.
- [Ruddiman] I've gotten this question a
lot over the last 10 or 12 years. And I
have an answer that's well rehearsed but
it's changed a little bit. I usually start
off by saying, "I was born a naive
idealist and I aged into a gentle cynic."
My assessment of the level of human
selfishness, there are plenty of wonderful
people in the universe, there are a lot of
very selfish people too . And so I think
left to their own devices, people that
large would not sacrifice to a solution
even though many of you may. I usually
then say, "I don't get asked to give
inspirational speeches." However, the
last couple of years, I've started to
shift that opinion and that is, there are
things happening technologically with
solar rays and battery storage and a
number of other areas that so far they are
incremental but they are accelerating.
And I see the possibility of something
that's just absolutely transformative in
the next, even in the next five years,
much less the next 10 or 20. So I'm not
quite the cynic that I was five years ago.
- [Potts] I guess I'm a glass half full
kind of guy. In 2005, there was of course
on Christmas day there was the terrific
loss of life. Two hundred and seventy some
thousand people was it? I can't remember
the exact number, but due to the Tsunami
hitting Indonesia. And there was a science
reporter for the Washington Post who wrote
an article a couple of weeks later, saying
that he had been at the December meeting
of the American Geophysical Union. And he
heard a talk, which had a title that went
on forever, which had words like,
subduction zones and things like this.
It described exactly what happened on that
Christmas day, exactly. And the Washington
Post science writer said, the only thing
that scientists couldn't say is, "Run. Run
for your lives!" And I think that what
that communicates to me and I hope to all
of us is that we won't make progress just
simply, just only by trying to throw
evidence, throw data at people and expect
them to understand.
Data is no guarantee for caring.
And no matter what we argue from a
scientific standpoint, it's no guarantee
for caring and for acting. And so I am
optimistic partly because we have the
capacity, not only as scientists but
people involved in society and working
with young people and people from all
walks of society to activate a moral
conscience and a societal conscience, that
makes use of the fact that we are
culturally contingent species. And that
means that we have the ability to make
choices and that we have the ability to
act in ways that change life and lives and
our understanding of our relationship to
the planet. Historians can point to much
like Naomi did to matters of slavery, in
South Africa the end of apartheid, matters
of with regard to global climate.
The response ultimately
to the ozone hole and
the end of CFC use.
And actually the tipping point go to use
the term that Liz Hadley used, the tipping
point in society and all of those
societies actually took years, just years
to do. Not 10 years. Of course, there was
a big build up, but it took years to do.
And I think that we have the possibility
of doing that and developing ethics,
morality, compassion that is joined at the
hip with the science that we presented
today. And as co-chair, I can only point
out that Charlie was also a member of our
panel today and so he needs to answer.
- [Charles] So, I think that when
you look at the
well, first of all let's just realize what
you heard was scientists speaking today.
And we all live inside our disciplines and
we all live inside a limited sphere of
knowledge. But we are all pessimistic it
would seem because to a person in the
sustainability arena, each of us would
say, within our limited perception that
we've never seen problems quite of this
scale. And more than that, nobody is
listening. Those are big problems, and so
we are pessimistic. But you have to step
back from the structured knowledge that
we've tried to relate to you and think
more philosophically. We are thinking
about the next century but I'd like to
point out the tremendous problems in the
last century that our grandparents and
parents solved. They solved, they grew,
the century started with terrible mass
warfare. Conflicts between dictators, much
reduced. The nuclear threat
unprecedented much reduced.
Colonialism, gone to a large extent. And
finally, we began to solve the fundamental
problem of the third world. And we now
have set, as a civilization the forbidding
on the way to a decent way of life. So
these are enormous transformations in
society that took place that no one in the
year 1900 could have predicted, much less
the airlines and space travel. And so I
count on the creativity of human beings,
this enormously competent culture that we
all live in, I count on increased
connectivity in that culture. And that
connectivity is sustained and propagated
by our concern for each other and the
ethical concern that we will develop for
ourselves as a civilization and for our
climate environment as a whole. So with
that, I commend you for staying with us,
complicated and long and very informative
technical discussion. I hope you'll give
all our speakers a chance
and some applause.
- [Margaret Schoeninger] I'm Margaret
Schoeninger, I'm one of the co-directors
of CARTA and I want to just thank
everyone. I would like to start really
with our co-chairs. That was just the
phenomenal series of presentations that
you have put together. I would also like
to speak to the speakers. Each one of you,
I think the thing that struck me was how
integrated you were. Even though I don't
know that you knew that when you started,
but it brought us a whole piece of
something. I greatly appreciate that. And
I will also thank our supporters. There
may be many of you in this room, but there
are many people who are our supporters who
are not in this room. And so I want to
thank the people who have supported us.
And finally, I want to thank the audience.
And also want to say that those were the
best set of questions I think I have heard
at a CARTA symposium. So I want to thank
you all of you for thinking this through
and asking some very simulating questions.
So I will now close, and thank you all for
and thank you all for a great speaking.